just crushed a squat workout sure you
did
you don't believe me i was squatting
next to you
you don't think i crushed it i think i
crushed it i mean after taking a
10-minute poop
and i still came back it hit my and i
hit my last set yeah i think you were
like on set number three or four and
then you left for 10 minutes and i
needed two different people to spot me
because that's how long you took and
then you came back
no warm up no nothing and then you
squatted your last one i was like [ __ ]
yep
shout outs to the performance greens
right here
because it uh got my bowel movements
going from eating like trash this
weekend and it actually feels really
good because i never trained back at
barbell on a monday anymore i always
come in for jk news right so i might
train on a wednesday or friday
um but to come back here on a monday and
fill the monday energy vibe it felt
really good and we're out here because
taika doesn't have school this week how
was your training
that's good um i noticed all that [ __ ]
hey i wasn't taking a [ __ ] though
um i don't know it just feels hard to
get feel strong when i wake up hella
early oh i woke up at five today which
is an hour later than when i normally
wake up because i normally wake up at
four but out here for some reason i
think i'm extra comfortable so i want to
just shut your mama's house you big cuny
maybe or just maybe like the fact that i
have to get up get ready and then get in
the car and go like i know the luxury
that i have just getting up getting
ready going downstairs i'm there oh all
the extra stuff yeah yeah there's just
like a lot of things already like i wake
up and i'm like oh [ __ ] traffic gotta go
ah so i think i just wake up with the i
don't know maybe i just make a little
[ __ ] and that's what it sounds like it
sounds psychic yeah just yeah i think
that's what it really snatched
i'm just kidding i love you so much
now i'm glad you had a really good
workout i'm gonna give you a big fat
kiss
and then that is gonna make your day so
much better now
okay yeah
do you feel it
yeah
back in the barbell brigade office
just me and my cuny patina
do you miss working here week to week oh
i love an office environment it does
it's like way more professional huh and
you're zoned in yeah you're super locked
in and like everyone is has the same
objective yeah whereas at home it's like
the bed's right there oh i wonder what's
in the fridge oh what time is it like
you just have at least for me i just
feel like i have more excuses or like oh
is that the laundry oh my god this is
out of place let me put that away like i
just have too many distractions whereas
here i'm like
locked in zone in i see everyone else
working and putting out and i'm like oh
[ __ ] i gotta keep going do you think
you'll ever
like the home environment environment
more you know like the pandemic kid
everyone was working remote and it seems
like a lot of people really like just
waking up and working um i guess if i
was doing solo work yeah but when it
comes to creative work i really like the
collaboration oh yeah like a team oh you
feel that vibe and the energy the energy
i really do like that but if i'm doing
like crunching numbers and [ __ ] or like
i have to really concentrate and it's
not creative then i yeah i would just
stay at home that's true and we're a
creative company so yeah it's not
happening yeah because we get to like oh
mystery box what's this oh we can put
this where you put this with this
together and then you got this and you
put the onion put the pads they put the
pads with the with the with the
supplements down there and you put the
supplements and then you can brainstorm
all kind of cool videos so yeah i do
miss working with the team so i'm so
happy i'm back here this week
slowly get to see everyone come in
so from training we came straight here
we haven't showered and checked this
nasty guy out well wait maybe i'm more
nasty because i'm not even gonna do what
he does but let's put as much as he does
[Music]
it's cold
yeah that's really cool hey kitty what
are you doing
we don't have a shower here
so i'm just doing my own little like
possible like being sticky
and i also
like i like getting into modes you know
what i mean like you know when you go
clubbing you want to like look all
dolled up
like i like to be in work mode
so when i'm in work mode i don't like
being in like
like sticky outfits
like sticky gym clothes so i like being
okay
here's another phase of my day
work time you know
just like how like when i sleep i either
like
soft
pajamas
or be naked yeah but now you're just
spreading that sweat on the rest of your
body but it's clean
sweat no right now right now what are
you talking about sweat you're just
spreading it all over your body you're
not changing i've never liked the table
before you're pretty interesting
yeah i have ever seen if it's streaky
that's because you're using the exact
same side that has all the build up of
food and all that oils and [ __ ] no you
just gotta do it couple times no and
then you're supposed to fold it over
look you haven't folded it over once i
did
where i'm what do you mean i'm looking
at you you're taking the nice pheromones
and moisture like that
the lubrication and then now
did i moisturize my face
no no no no no no no see now my legs
won't even be sticky
i'll just kick it the way i am man
you just got [ __ ] you got underarm
juice you you got pit juice all over
your [ __ ] face
yeah smell it [ __ ] no
that's why my face is so youthful i'm
actually 57.
how come you said you feel like you're
just trying to [ __ ] fight
youthful no because you don't know what
the hell you're doing i can't watch this
i'm the only clean person in this i
don't know about that man you're nasty
look at you look at you
should be ashamed of yourself
see see i just washed it all off like
that oh yeah
oh yeah
okay you can buy your pit and now you're
gonna go get your face again oh that's
that's where you prevent actually elbows
but you always have ashy elbows no
because i haven't done this in a while
you like this
and you put in the elbow see
now it's nice and clean
get that neck area
get the under boob
i'm leaving oh i can't believe i
suggested subjected you guys to that i'm
so sorry
who's this [ __ ] oh yeah this is longer
lens i'm vlogging you vlogging me oh
yeah
justin's is a short stubby fat one
this lens is crazy i mean your camera is
long oh yes so long i could reach like
that bam right there whoa it's about the
motion in the ocean the camera oh that's
true all the angles we all know that
dustin's foot is going to look way
better
oh yeah look at this cool angle yeah
look at that oh yeah
look he has a big tree in it you already
stuck with your box oh man oh he has a
tree oh yeah
oh yeah look at this look at this
kaleidoscope look at this euphoria
euphoria
[Applause]
euphoria dude
okay
what is going on what is that
what is that the headset
what's going on i do the headstand yeah
there's a nice handstand you did on the
couch
that's amazing hey you got shoes on the
couch dude gotta get the straight get
your shoes off the couch young man
i just got back home from work
this is cuny working with everyone
i am
very tired though because uh it worked
from what
i think like got to the office like
around eight
eight till five
yeah that's a pretty
normal work day maybe i'm just being a
little [ __ ]
what in the easy
that is taika
this will stuff my jammas into my lamp
onto the lamp right here look at this oh
my goodness
honestly though i love little souvenirs
like this i love coming home it's seeing
that the house is a mess
it energizes me because it just feels so
cute
that he left like his little trail of
crumbs this little trail of um
crumbs of mischief
as i would like to call it
and so i like discovering like seeing
like it's like a random being taped to
the wall or whatever you know
i guess i'm getting in trouble
who's getting in trouble
oh no no no no no no no no
one of my favorite things about taika
being at grandma's house
is this guy
plays to the last
drop of gas like literally he's running
around the whole property
with his cousins
and then he's like bouncing off the
walls in here and they're watching the
movie and until the very last drop like
on the couch i just picked them up
brought him here and good thing grandma
had his pjs
underneath his regular clothes
because
all you have to do is just take off his
regular clothes and this guy is
out
even though he's out he looks like he's
pretending
hey monkey
would you like some chocolate
some delicious chocolate or candy
does he look like he's smiling
and you know he's freaking out
and grandma has his milk to drink
because he loves his milk
but he didn't even drink it he is out
out with his stuffies
are you pretending
hey monkey are you pretending
all right man today is the day that i
pick up my truck
damn
oh
am i ready to go to a car show
damn play a player
player play yeah
are y'all ready dude let me show you the
front end cause man
damn plan
look at that oh i got my skid plate i
got my lights
i got my camera got my action bam bam
look at that oh
man now the tires look papa lopping look
at that
i love that high angle right there you
know what i'm saying
look at that
oh now you can see what i'm working with
you know what i mean
oh they fixed the sticker
because uh they had an old sticker that
came and the fox wasn't facing out
so people don't know what time it is and
i was telling them like yo
you know it's all about instagram so i
gotta make sure that people know what
time it is
oh yeah i got my leaf springs my beavers
oh the r81's right there
so what those do is uh on my black truck
if you guys remember my silverado had a
really nice cushy like cadillac type
feel
and i took deep relief springs for
granted so i just got shocks all around
so the shocks help adjust the travel
but then in the back you also have leaf
springs because in the front you have
coils right so the the mechanism that
helps like stabilize is both the shocks
and the coils
so you kind of have like a metal
component and you kind of have a gas
component
and i had the gas unlocked because i had
the fox shocks but the leaf springs
were my old ones and sometimes i'll go
over speed bumps and it'll like bump a
little bit and i'm like oh man it's not
as bump uh bump friendly as my black
truck so
when i got this hooked up i had to throw
the leaf uh the d release rings in the
back
and oh baby baby
that's what i'm talking about got them
lights on too
these are pretty dope like area lights
so these help out a lot when like you're
going out into the middle of the desert
and if you're uh
like camping shooting whatever because
when you're out in the middle of desert
there's no street lights like the city
so it's pitch black you need some area
lights to either like dig through your
gear or whatever and this helps out if
people are behind you
and they all up on you you can just give
them a little tap and then and then
they'll let them know that oh shoot too
up close and personal it's almost like
being able to control your reverse light
so your regular reverse lights you can
only control through the shifter
well um
this one i could control
through uh a button and i completely
forgot that joe crashed into my car
oh it would have been so perfect
oh
still got to get that fixed but
damn looking hard son
what's up guys we are in california
still
and in the barbell brigade office
if you haven't noticed we got papa
our team meets in person three times a
week monday tuesday wednesday and we do
that because um nothing is faster than
in prince in person communication so you
get answers done super quick um since we
moved to vegas i mean since the world
shut down honestly we had to move
everything online
and even though online is super
convenient it's still super inconvenient
because now
you're waiting on the other person's
like schedule and you're hoping that
your guys's schedules line up so that
you get the answers when you need them
on your schedule if that makes sense
um
so
yeah it's super convenient to meet
online and it's comfortable right
because you're like business on top
party or pleasure on the bottom uh where
you can still be in your pages and stuff
but if you need an answer right away
you're kind of at the mercy of their
schedule whenever they're online or
they're working on that specific thing
but when you're in person
if i just have like a two minute
question that i need answered or or i
need an update out something i go hey
bart
yeah there it is
can i bug you real quick
no i'm feeding my cat online right now
yeah well in person that wouldn't happen
right so i'd be like gonna boogie real
quick and then i bug them real quick and
then we're done with it and then i can
move on i can continue pushing the
project forward so um we really wanted
to do that um in the office so we do
have three days of in-person meeting um
um but then the rest of the week it's
whatever your schedule is right
so it's been really cool being back in
getting these answers quickly and just
being in the energy of our team it was
so cool we had a marketing meeting
yesterday and it was fun we did some
taste testing um we're coming out with
new supplement flavors ah
but we have to get the flavors down
correctly
so we have the whole team uh taste them
whoever wants to be involved of course
um and and we get feedback and we play
and and we get to listen to music and we
eat together and it's just it's just
different so i love being here
i get extra motivated i get like i don't
i just like working with people that
aren't just this guy all the time
what nothing
how'd you know let's talk about you
as the latinos say but here's the
burning man
guy's an idiot
um but today unfortunately is a thursday
and tomorrow's friday which means we're
gonna have the office all to ourselves
which is fine and all but i do miss the
team i do wish i could be in their
energy uh maybe i should just go to
someone's house imagine i just go to
knock someone's door hey i'm gonna work
with you today they're like
no absolutely not get the [ __ ] out of
here um
yeah literally creep but it's nice it's
nice being in here and kind of just
being surrounded by everything barbell
like over here
we have our gym set up
for shoots and stuff we're uh justin is
on location right now shooting with a
few of our models because we do have a
launch coming up in about two weeks
so getting that wrapped up
but um yeah it just feels good like
everywhere i look it's like barbell
barbell barbell barbell
barbell
i love it it's really nice
um
can you guys guess what this what bart
uses this towel for
well
look at how stiff this thing is
what the [ __ ] are you talking about what
are you talking about
yeah anyway
stiff towel you know what it does with
it
all right so wrapping it up ready to go
on our little day
oh my god
i hope i
i don't know should i put out you guys
like
should i have sex with him
i'm just kidding um
yeah but uh yeah put everything away
i'm like a bag lady when i come out here
like i have
my bag here that holds my other bags
obviously masks but i bring my makeup
bag because you never know you never
know what's gonna pop off and like you
want to be ready i have this
face
base i don't even know how to say it
um
i love it because it has a little mirror
and then it has this compartment that's
magnetic that i could put on my brushes
and stuff i feel like i have like a tool
it's like a toolbox
um it has a zipper for more storage and
then obviously i have all my makeup in
here
um my favorite i don't even know who
makes this oh
who makes this
oh physicians formula drugstore but my
favorite blush as you can tell it broke
and i'm still
trying to make it work
um and it has compartments on the side
here
and on the side here i bring this little
thing that has um
bobby pins
but yeah
i got this like daiso years ago
and it holds all of my
eyelashes because you never know you
never know when you gotta be cute
with one hand here
there we go
yeah so i have my little eyelashes here
eyeshadows and i try to bring a pellet
that i could wear
like during the day and night so i can
dress up or down in so i used i brought
this one
a lot of neutral
natural tones and this one is by okay
this is gifted for sure oh color color
pop
and then i always try to bring boxes
that i can wear daytime and
so bring that with me
i always bring a speaker because i like
to tr uh
i like to listen to music when i work or
just in here in the office i like having
just music or if we go on a picnic or i
don't know an adventure or something i
always have it with me so
um i can always party but yeah bring a
big bag and then i don't like purses
so i love this because you can dress up
or down it's leather it's from all
saints i think it was like 300
but it's
leather so it's very durable like i said
i've had it for years already
and it looks brand new so yeah it's a
little bit pricey but it is an
investment
um and it's just gonna be quality so
it's gonna look quality
but yeah it came with the straps so you
can
wear it like a purse if you'd like or
like a crossbody but i do prefer it as a
backpack because i just don't like
holding anything in my hands and it's a
perfect size not too big not too small
and then i
almost don't carry anything like i have
maybe like
tampon
keys but it already has my wallet on it
because literally this is all i travel
with at home this is all i need but when
i'm not at home
you know i never know whether they'll
take me so i try to bring a couple
things
with me in case i buy something or i
want more glosses on me or something the
rest of the pockets are completely empty
this is so funny
can you see this one do i have anything
in here nope i always have gloss
and some kind of like lip tint with me
yep
there it is
magnetic clothes i have that and then
this right here is my favorite backpack
of all time that i always travel with
it's our barbell brigade backpack as you
can see it's the our logo has been
scratched off that's how much i use it
but i
love love love it i have
um ipad my planner just work documents
uh my laptop
i'm like
really [ __ ] organized
at least i think i am let me see if i
can
set this down here real quick because i
want to show you
and
i like
all the pockets it has it looks like i'm
selling this to you but i'm
we don't even have these anymore but
yeah so many compartments super pushy
has a secret pocket back here
um i think it has one little pocket on
one of these things no it doesn't
hold my bottle of water or whatever
a little pocket up here for like pencils
lip gloss
a ton of storage in here and this is
what i love
i carry these things and i learned this
from just going to school
i have my pencil bag where i have like
my essentials right like whiteout
um eraser
pens highlighters lead pencil lead
pens what have you and then this is all
my
like electronic chargers and stuff and
i don't like things being all sloppy and
messy and tangled so i buy like these
little rubber bands you can get any of
these things there's some that are
magnetic you have one that's magnetic in
here nope it's on the other one
um but this one isn't you just kind of
tie it but it keeps everything super
organized so if i'm looking for a
specific charger
you can find it right away oh and i
always travel
with the hot spot because again you
never know when you need it if you have
to work or you know for entertainment
for kids or if you're
um
i don't know stuck somewhere but you
have horrible reception but at least
there's enough uh like wi-fi that
reaches there and you have an iphone you
can use that so i
always put this stuff away
what else what else
oh i always travel with
my mouse
i have a mouse that i always always
always travel with it's just easier to
navigate and move this instead of like
always being on the
track pad
and uh yeah that's what i travel with
all the time i feel like a mega bag of
lady oh
and water shout out to cassie aka
blogalotties
for making the best water jug
stay hydrated my friends
okay
this is what i'm wearing today
not sure if i like it
but we're working with it
it's cold in l.a right now let me see
let me see how
cold it is i'm not used to this oh okay
it's gonna be 37 degrees tonight that is
crazy right now it's 63 but like the
wind feels
so cold
or i'm just being a little [ __ ] one or
the other but i rather blame the wind
yeah i'm gonna do that
so we are now in the parking lot or
parking structure of our date location
we decided to come to the glendale uh
galleria or maybe the it's called brand
right americana
yeah yes we're at the americana
if you guys have never been here in
glendale definitely come here it's so
cute for families and for for states or
if you're from out of town or out of
state definitely check it out it has
like a bunch of shops eateries um it's
just a really cute spot here so um i'm
gonna enjoy some time with my papa i'm
gonna leave you guys behind and then
i'll catch her up i'll let you know how
it went i'm like a little bit nervous
are you nervous i'm just kidding i was
pretending to get the first date oh i
thought cause you're trying to have sex
in a bathroom somewhere
that's like some like college stuff
i don't do that anymore
okay
so we went on our date
fell asleep with makeup
came back
had a beautiful time though
had a beautiful time but now we're
reunited with the bubble man
let me see those hips that's again with
your hips
socks let me see the bottom of your
socks they have like little sticky
rubbers you know these sponsor are just
kidding you shop yeah
they're sick
oh wait then why did i pay why did i pay
money for these guys
you just support good brands for every
pair you buy they donate to someone in
need
oh cool then they donated because i got
two pairs
what are we doing today
so tutu is my brother that uh his name
is tito
and the kids call him tutu well not the
kids just this kid well the kids that
aren't his own kid because they call him
dad obviously um and he just wants to
hang out with them in their house
because
um that's where all the kids are i'm
trying to get away from this kid cause
all these bubbles
can you tell which one's my mom's room
oh my god it's so dark
there we go
versus the room we're staying in
it looks like
things just kind of exploded over here
but yeah it's always so cute being here
because this is the house i grew up in
hold on it's a little
dirty
what are you doing give me give me hey
give me your bushy go
but growing up this was our living room
here and we had a couch here
and that's where my brother slept
that was his room he slept here for i
don't know how many years
and then
this was a master bedroom this is where
my parents bed was
and their bed was here so the headboard
would be here
oh my god
they slipped on it i don't
remember actually i think it was here
whoa
that is so cool
but it's still a poppable yeah
um and then
my mom still has this thing so they had
this when i was growing up this was
there
and then this was their closet
this was their closet
i don't remember if it had doors or not
i don't know if it was like this
i don't remember it
okay we don't want to do that because
grandma's going to slip and fall hold on
i'm going to try to prevent deaths in
this house one second
okay tech is going to wipe the floor um
so the
that was that room here was my sister's
bedroom and it used to be this lavender
purple which it still kind of is i think
my mom just painted this one wall that
color
and she had a bunch of stuffed animals
all over wait i kind of remember vaguely
oh her bed was over here
yeah her bed was here
yeah and i would share a room with her
before like
maybe until i was
trying to think this before my little
sister was born so i think it was
until i was like
six
yeah shared a room with her
and yeah i grew up in this house until i
was six and then we moved into the back
house where my brother lives now so i
just grew up on this whole lot
so it's always cuny coming back because
there's just so many memories throughout
this entire property that i absolutely
love i
loved growing up here um
i mean i don't know anything else so i
don't know if i would say i would change
anything but
they were really cool memories you know
um our house went through a lot of
remodeling not this one so much but the
one in the back and just the outside
because we used to have a huge lemon
tree out front
um and it was a walkway but now like my
dad laid cement all over it and now it's
like this really long driveway where you
can park like a million cars and stuff
so
um i love being back here